[Applause]
it's time for
pop quiz
all right
we've got this fabulous money booth here
for one special audience member to step
into it and it has how much rossi
[Applause]
and if you grab the gold ticket you're
also going to win a grand prize
and if the person grabs the silver
ticket the entire audience will go home
[Applause]
okay
where is our audience member gwen dubbo
where are you
[Applause]
oh hi gwen i was just complimenting you
on your head to tell love yes obsessed
with this jumpsuit thank you we're going
to ask you
three questions
about everything that neil patrick
harris mentioned throughout the show and
ross well then what happens well then
you're going to get 10 seconds for every
correct answer inside this booth and
then you better grab all right
yes
okay
first question are we ready what kind of
cookies danielle say that his husband
makes him for the holidays one of my
favorite dishes that he makes
are cookies
he makes these peanut butter cookies
peanut butter
question number two for ten more seconds
what does neil use as holiday decor that
makes it look like it's snowing on the
side of his house and i found these
disco balls that are inside a box and a
light shines on them and they slowly
rotate and it looks like it's snowing
disco balls two of them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is the name of the golden retriever
puppy that santa gave to neil's twins
we
gave
via our friend santa claus a gift to our
kids the gift of a golden retriever
puppy her name is ella
and little known fact her middle name
is menope so if you put them together
her name is ella novi
ella menopy
all right we want you to throw that
apron and goggles on because we don't
want any shards of cash to hit your eyes
and then um we just want you you know to
go animal if you'd care to do so um
great now tie it around your waist so
it's nice and secure so that you've got
your marsupial cash pouch
a cash kangaroo yeah right all right now
good luck step on in the booth okay
[Applause]
just go for it start it do it go go go
all right 30 seconds on the clock
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she did
okay oh god right here right here oh
girl grab that hundred dollars
right here all right
okay
when
that's how you do it
when you are silent but deadly i love it
so much all right we're going to go to a
quick commercial break and then we're
going to count the cash that you got and
see if you got the silver or the gold
dollar and we'll be right back okay
[Applause]
[Music]
30 seconds to collect as much money as
she could in our money booth gwen are
you ready to find out how much you've
won yes gwen wow you grabbed 2 115
[Applause]
[Music]
and if that's not enough that's more
than anyone's ever grabbed in the booth
you also grabbed
the silver tape
with an i-home glow ring oversized
vanity speaker look at
i'm not kidding did you and i just have
the same thought i was like wow that
looks really cool yeah all right
you for congratulations
to spend your time
[Music]
you